bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
merci de votre fidélité vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux à suivre sens
public à 18h ou 22h mais aussi en replay
sur notre plateforme publicsenna.fr ou
sur la chaîne Youtube Public Sénat bref
merci et on va évidemment continuer de
donner du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
invités experts je vous propose tout de
suite le sommaire de ce 20 novembre
rencontre de Saint-Denis conseil
nationale de la refondation et avant
cela le grand débat on ne pourra pas
reprocher à Emmanuel Macron d'avoir
manqué d'imagination pour redonner du
souffle à notre 5e République mais pour
l'instant ça ne marche pas comment
dépasser le piège de la com
présidentielle notre classe politique
est-elle inapte au compromis faut-il
redonner la parole au peuple grâce au
référendum on répond à toutes ces
questions dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat c'est un zoom sur les
élections présidentielles américaines
que je vous propose ces gens sont
arrivés au pouvoir je ne dirai pas
comment mais vous savez comment et tout
a explosé de partout Donald Trump à la
frontière mexicaine qui continue de
remettre en cause la légitimité de
l'élection de Joe Biden voilà le climat
d'une campagne qui voit le candidat
républicain reprendre la tête dans les
sondages à moins d'un an du scrutin
quelle est la stratégie de Donald Trump
pour revenir au pouvoir Joe Biden le
président Biden est-il trop vieux pour
un second mandat Pourquoi la nouvelle
génération n'a pas pris pris la main
dans les deux camps on répond à ces
questions dans trois quart d'heure mais
d'abord donc les pistes pour réformer
nos institutions avec Cécile sexou
terminé le référendum ouvert aux
questions d'immigration c'est fini on n'
parle plus après les rencontres de
Saint-Denis vendredi dernier Emmanuel
Macron abandonne l'idée de réformer
l'article 11 de la Constitution car les
parlementaires excepter ceux de droite
n'en veulent pas il y a deux personnes
qui le portaient fortement l'une n'est
même pas venue et donc je ne comprends
pas à quoi ça sert de porter fortement
une proposition que le président la
mette à l'ordre du jour d'une réunion et
vous venez même pas sur des prétextes
fallacieux auquel personne n'a rien
compris résultat il y avait une
unanimité à part Jordane Bardella qui
était assez esselé sur le sujet pour
dire que ça n'était absolument pas le
moment enterrer aussi l'élargissement du
référendum d'initiative partagé le
fameux RIP il devait s'ouvrir et être
possible sur propositions citoyennes et
à des seuils plus accessibles mais là
encore cutif jette l'éponges faute de
majorité avec les républicains ou sans
les républicains l'ensemble des
formations politiques était défavorable
donc ça sert à rien de mettre euh
dans le tuyau parlementaire des textes
qui n'ont aucune chance de prospérer
politiquement en revanche on connaît
désormais le calendrier de l'inscription
de l'IVG dans la Constitution la réforme
sera présenté le 13 décembre en conseil
des ministres pour un congrès prier
trimestre 2024 dans les tuyaux également
la réforme constitutionnelle sur le
statut de la Nouvelle-Calédonie enfin le
président souhaite ouvrir le chantier de
la décentralisation il a confié une
mission à Eric vert en vue d'une réforme
mais là encore rien n'est gagné je ne
crois pas moi non plus un nouveau Big
Bang territorial je le redirai à Eric
vert la priorité n'est pas la réduction
du nombre de strat sans majorité à
l'Assemblée et avec un Sénat dans
l'opposition difficile de faire passer
ces réformes
Emmanuel Macron pourrait revivre les
tentatives ratées de révision
constitutionnelle de son premier
quinena pourquoi les innovations
institutionnelles d'Emmanuel Macron font
pit voilà le thème de notre débat avec
Anne Charlen Bina bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes constitutionnaliste Richard
verli bonsoir et bienvenue correspondant
France Europe pour le méia Suisse bque
et vous venez de lancer votre podcast
elvéti café voilà le deuxème épisode
c'est demain il est consacré à Brigitte
Macron j'accueille bat Giblin bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes géographe et
directrice de la revue Hérodote Mathieu
croissandau bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue
éditorialiste politique on va pas
refaire toute la liste mais grands
débats Conseil national de la
refondation et les rencontres de
Saint-Denis an Charline Bina je le
disais en titre le Président il compte
pas ses efforts quand même pour innover
en matière constitutionnelle est-ce que
c'est une mission
impossible c'est une grande question de
savoir si on peut réformer la
Constitution sans y toucher puisque en
quelque sorte c'est aller au-delà du du
processus décisionnel de base qui
consiste à avoir un gouvernement qui se
confronte à son parlement et pourtant
nécessairement la décision devra
reprendre ce ce circuit à la fin pour
être conforme à la Constitution donc ça
veut dire qu'on consulte mais ça veut
dire qu'on consulte sans vraiment
s'engager sur le résultat et moi je
crois que c'est vraiment ça le problème
de ces différents outils c'est-à-dire
que vous prenez le pou des partis
politiques de la population les
conventions citoyennes c'est un
échantillonnage et il y a forcément
quelque chose d'un peu déceptif à
ensuite récupér une décision publique
qui va forcément être gouvernementale
dont la synthèse va être politique et et
et je crois que tenter beaucoup de
choses c'est bien et permet un peu
évidemment de de renouveler un peu le
chptel mais je crains qu'il ait
forcément toujours à la clé une une
déception au niveau du résultat ou
est-ce que c'est d'abord Richard Verly
pour le président de la République un
moyen d'occuper l'espace médiatique ou
est-ce qu'il y a quand même une volonté
de voilà avec une une donnée d'équilibre
politique qu'on connaît voilà de de de
prouver qu'il est là pour discuter pour
dialoguer pour tenter le compromis
écoutez sans doute les deux ce qui est
certain c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron il a
bien compris et la crise des gilets
jaunes lui avait montré avec violence
que une grande partie des Français
veulent s'exprimer veulent participer à
d'autres moments qu'X séquence
électorale habituelle c'est-à-dire
législative ou présidentielle ça il l'a
bien compris il en a tiré les
conséquences il avait fait le grand
débat il a essayé le Conseil national de
refondation plus la convention citoyenne
sur le climat et cetera après est-ce
qu'il en a envie vraiment moi j'avoue
que j'ai un doute et je vais vous donner
tout simplement un exemple il était la
semaine dernière dans un pays que je
connais bien la Suisse qui est le pays
de la démocratie direct par excellence
et moi naïvement j'ai pensé que pendant
cette séquence il poserait au moins à
ses interlocuteurs suisses ne serait-ce
qu'au Conseil fédéral c'està-dire au
gouvernement les des questions comment
ça se passe la démocratie directe
comment vous faites rien zéro pas un mot
il n'a même pas prononcer en Suisse le
mot référendum donc si dans un pays
comme la Suisse vous ne vous intéressez
même pas au mécan alors que ça marche ça
veut dire franchement que vous ne devez
pas vous y intéresser tout court ouais
Béatrice giblelin il y a il faut être
deux hein pour pour danser Laval c'est
est-ce que ces rendez-vous manqués c'est
quand même aussi le signe d'une
incapacité de notre classe politique à
tout simplement pratiquer le compromis
moi c'est ce que je pense je pense qu'on
est dans un pays où l'idée compromis on
entend déjà compromission ce qui n'a
strictement rien à voir et on est pas à
l'aise avec le compromis on n'est pas à
l'aise dans le pas qu'on doit faire
chacun pour avancer et trouver
effectivement un terrain d'entente
c'està-dire que
l'intérêt supérieur de la nation
l'intérêt commun devrait entraîner à une
forme de j'allis dire d'être raisonnable
ils ont été élus moi je reviens sur
quand on a appris que cette chambre
n'avait pas de la majorité absolue mais
tout le monde était content en disant
mais ça y est on n'est plus avec une
chambre godillot ça va ça va débattre ça
va être intéressant c'était au fond ce
qu'on voulait on avait dit mon Dieu
quelle sagesse des électeurs comme s'ils
avaient fait ça volontairement mais bon
bref on va on va cétait pur hasard de
mon point de vue mais bon on va voir
autre chose on va voir véritablement un
parlement fonctionner et qu'est-ce qu'on
voit un parlement qui ne fonctionne pas
et qui à la limite pousse un certain
nombre de de nos concitoyens à
s'éloigner encore plus de la politique
en mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
cinéma est-ce qu' FNE pas ce ce ce
Parlement c'est là où j'apporte vol je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous sur
l'immaturité de de cette classe
politique j'ajoute que une grande partie
de ces partis politiques demande la
proportionnelle donc ils ont tous
inscrits dans leur programme la
proportionnelle la proportionnelle c'est
quoi ben c'est justement il y a pas une
majorité d'un bloc et il faut être
capable de battir des coalitions ou des
compromis qui ne sont pas des
compromissions donc il y a une espèce
d'hypocrisie monumentale de voir par
exemple la France insoumise qui inscrit
quasiment la proportionn intégrale le
rassemblement national ils y était donc
c'est c'est c'est différent mais de voir
certains partis le PS qui avait aussi
revendiqué la proportionnelle qui ne
sont pas là et en tout cas quand la
situation d'une d'une assemblée
composite se présente refuse parce que
la majorité on peut les coincer pendant
5 ans donc il préfère les coincer
pendant 5 ans ça c'est une immaturité
totale après est-ce que ce Parlement est
bloqué force de constater que c'est très
compliqué que ça accouche dans la
douleur qu'il faut beaucoup
d'aller-retour mais que ça accouche il y
a quand même des lois qui sont votéou on
peut juger ce qu'on ce qu'on veut ce
sont des bonnes ou des mauvaises lois
mais en tout cas c'est un parlement qui
légifère on est quand même obligé
d'admettre on reviendra sur la
proportionnelle votre avis sur un
parlement bloqué ou pas mais précisément
je ne pense pas forcément que le
Parlement soit bloqué mais eu égard à
des mécanismes institutionnels qui
permettent de le débloquer le 493
notamment c'est 493 notamment et et pas
uniquement c'est-à-dire que vous avez un
fait majoritaire établi sous la 5e
République qui fait que une majorité
même relative étant donné qu'elle est
dirigée par un gouvernement qui peut
récupérer on va dire le lead sur sa
majorité c'est le parlementarisme
rationalisé ben il n'y a pas de
véritable problème de fonctionnement
néanmoins on touche là à une autre
frontière qui est maintenant posée par
la population et ça c'est heureux
c'est-à-dire qu'on a un petit peu
entendu parler de la Constitution dans
la rue depuis la réforme des retraites
qui est la légitimité est-ce que
finalement avoir un parlementarisme
rationalisé quand on a une majorité
aussi courte c'est encore légitime alors
que on a eu un exemple avec Michel
Rocard dans les années 80 90 qui était
beaucoup moins mal vu par la population
qui considérait que bon euh les accords
étaient possibles un peu sur le centre
un peu plus à gauche mais ça restait du
consensus aujourd'hui on a le sentiment
que c'est ou euh une majorité qui va
devenir directive ou finalement une
faiblesse politique et euh je crois
vraiment que c'est ça l'enjeu des quatre
prochaines années qui nous attend c'est
arriver à être légitime à utiliser les
éléments qui permettent de débloquer la
situation tout en trouvant du consensus
politique ou en trouvant un petit peu à
élargir la majorité pour avoir cette
légitimité politique donc on est
vraiment dans un chemin très étroit ouis
chemin étroit notamment pour le
président de la République on va écouter
Emmanuel Macron c'était à l'occasion des
65 ans de la constitution de la 5e
République qu'il réaffirme ce jour-là sa
volonté de donner plus de force à la
souveraineté
populaire référendum
décentralisation au fond vous le voyez
il s'agit là de donner plus de force à
la souveraineté
populaire de retrouver plus d'efficacité
par plus de clarté des responsabilités
c'est je le crois l'esprit profond de
nos
institutions on était le 4 octobre
dernier Mathieu 5 6 semaines plus tard
la réunion de vendredi elle a enterré
toute véléité d'élargir le champ de ce
référendum oui on l'a vu hein c'était
pourtant pas faute d'avoir multiplié les
appels du pied mais en matière de
référendum comme dans d'autres sujets
ceux qui en parlent le plus en font
parfois le moins pour être tout à fait
juste l'arme du référendum elle n'a été
dégainée qu'une petite dizaine de fois
depuis 1958 ça fait quand même 18 ans
qu'on en a plus vu la couleur depuis ce
fameux 29 mai 2005 qui vit les Français
rejeter le projet de traité
constitutionnel européen oui mais voilà
depuis plusieurs mois que ce soit lors
de sa campagne présidentielle où
Emmanuel Macron avait évoqué un possible
référendum sur les retraites dont on n
pas pas vu la couleur non plus hein que
ce soit en lançant le Conseil national
de laurfondation il en avait parlé aussi
le chef de l'État semblait navoir plus
que ce mot-là à la bouche souvenez-vous
même cet été grand grand entretien au
point et le mot référendum revient tout
au long tout au long de l'interview en
fait il avait envoyé un double signal
aux oppositions un assouplissement des
règles du référendum d'initiative
partagé pour la gauche et puis pour la
droite un élargissement du champ du
référendum aux questions sociétales et
pourquoi pas l'immigration alors que cet
outil on le sait il est aujourd'hui
réservé à l'organisation des pouvoirs
publicqus à la ratification des traités
et puis aux questions de politique
économique sociale ou même
environnemental depuis que ça a été
changé en 2008 en fait le piège était
admirablement tendu hein un pour la
gauche un pour la droite malheureusement
pour Emmanuel Macron ni la gauche ni la
droite ne sont tombé dedans puisque le
PS comer se sont même abstenus de faire
on l'a vu tout à l'heure le déplacement
et donc exite cette modification du
référendum oui le président n'a pu que
se rendre à l'évidence il y a pas de
consensus c'est le c'est le mot qui qui
est ressorti il allait quand même pas
offrir ce cadeau au seul qu'il demandait
autour de la table qui était Jordan
Bardella le président du Rassemblement
national mais c'est un renoncement qui
lui coûte tout aant car même si
l'histoire ne dit pas si ce référendum
et largie auraiit pu voir le jour et
puis encore moins si Macron l'aurait
utilisé ça constituait quand même une
porte de sortie disons pour un pouvoir
sans majorité on vient d'en parler au
Parlement et il y a encore quelques
semaines de cela souvenez-vous hein
certains gouvernement comme le ministre
de la transition écologique Christophe
Béchu comme le porte-parole Olivier
verérrant rêvit même d'un référendum à
choix multiple vous savez le fameux
préférendum sur les questions sociétales
pour faire trancher des sujets récurrent
comme la fin de vie la légalisation du
cannabis au français en redonnant un
mandat clair et du souffle bref un élan
au président et ben caramba encore raté
il va falloir retrouver autre chose
Richard verli vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure vous vous qui êtes les pro du
référendum en Suisse à quel rythme
sont-ils utilisés alors il y a au moins
quatre votations au pluriel par an
c'est-àdire quatre fois les électeurs
suisses vont aux urnes pour des
votations qui sont soit fédérales
c'estàd au niveau national soit cantonal
soit local donc un électeur Suisse à
l'assurance quatre fois par an d'être
consulté sur des sujets je dirais
d'intérêts généraux et qui décide du
contenu de référendum alors ça dépend
vous avez les deux vous avez soit les
référendums qui portent sur des lois qui
ont été passées par le gouvernement mais
qui sont soumis au peuple donc c'est un
principe en quelque sorte possiblement
révocatoire une loi votée peut être
révoquée ou bien ce sont les fameuses
initiatives qui peuvent viser à réformer
la Constitution donc il viennent de la
base moyennant un certain nombre de
signatures mais il y a un élément que je
qu'on pourrait ajouter à la chronique de
Mathieu c'est les Français ils le
veulent ce référendum et là à mon avis
il y a un problème c'est que le pays est
bloqué le pays regardez toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion un peu près à 70 % je
crois les Français disent on voudrait
pouvoir davantage avoir davantage de
référendum donc de ce point de vue-là
Emmanuel Macron il a raison or les
partis politiques leur répondent non
vous n'y aurez pas droit moi je sais pas
où ça peut mener mais il y a un moment
donné où ça ne fait à mon avis qu'atiser
la colère ambiante 18 ans sans
référendum Mathieu l'a rappelé un
charine Bina c'est quoi c'est un c'est
devenu un épuventail à président de la
République un peu comme la dissolution
d'ailleurs c'est-à-dire que les mes
usages dans l'histoire constitutionnelle
française ont parfois installé des des
épouvantails comme vous le dites
c'est-à-dire que c'est dans le texte
mais on a peur de les utiliser j'ajoute
que on croit souvent à voir le peu
d'usage du référendum que c'est quelque
chose d'assez complexe que c'est lourd
or c'est vraiment le le général de GA le
disait comme ça la rencontre d'un peuple
et de sa nation c'est-à-dire que c'est
le président qui décide de poser une
question et le lendemain ça peut être
tout simplement ficelé en tout cas dans
son organisation donc c'est très simple
la seule chose c'est qu'il faut en avoir
la volonté po et aujourd'hui c'est pas
la liste des sujets qui nous manque
alors l'immigration certes paraissait ne
pas pouvoir rentrer dans dans la liste
que nous avons à l'heure actuelle mais
les sujets qui impactent les finances de
la nation les sujets qui impactent
l'organisation sociale de la nation
l'environnement l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics tout cela n'a presque
jamais fait l'usage d'un référendum sous
la 5e République on l'a utilisé pour
ratifier des traités ou des
autodéterminations pour les commors en
l'occurrence donc on a vraiment pas eu
un usage de la du référendum sous la 5e
République qui soit vraiment signif i à
part sous le général de Gaulle qui
l'utilisait presque comme un plébiscde
personnel et je pense que c'est ça aussi
qui nous a laissé est-ce que vous pensez
que l'usage qui veut qu'un président
démission s'il perèd c'est quelque chose
de révolu ou c'est quelque chose qui qui
va rester quand même dans l'histoire on
rappelle que Jacques shirac n'a pas
démissionner après la victoire du nom au
référendum alors c'est peut-être une des
parties de l'épouvantail c'est-à-dire
qu'en effet le général de Gaulle
l'utilise en en engageant sa
responsabilité politique ce qui est une
conception de la responsabilité
politique c'estàd que dans la
Constitution vous ne pouvez pas démettre
le président donc soit ce dernier décide
que le référendum l'engage soit ce
dernier décide que ce référendum ne
l'engage pas et on est sur l'exemple de
Jacques shirac mais en effet l'idée que
le président est nécessairement à
engager sa responsabilité a fait peur et
je pense aujourd'hui que c'est pas
forcément l'attente des Français la
responsabilité politique chacun peut la
trouver c'est presque quelque chose
d'éthique et de morale au niveau du
président donc c'est pas le référendum
qui répondra à cette question mais je
pense que les deux appétences existent
dans l'opinion aussi bien plus de
responsabilité que pour le président
h oui et et moi j'aimais bien l'idée du
préférendum c'est même si le mot
n'existe pas vraiment dans la française
mais enfin sonder les Français sur
plusieurs questions en même temps alors
ça ça ça permettait d'éliminer le
côté épouvantail à présidence évidemment
voyez bien l'intérêt qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez ben je pense que dans
l'expérience qu'on a eu des référendums
c'est que souvent les Français n'ont pas
exactement répondu à la question qui
était posée c'était le cas en 2005 hein
c'était pour parce que personne navait
vraiment lu la constitution de B à Z on
était sans doute un peu un peu un peu
confiant ça s'est pas joué non plus dans
des avec une différence si massive et
puis on l'a contourné très rapidement
c'est ça aussi qui a posé problème au
français le sentiment que quand il
donnait un avis on n tenait paspd tenait
pas compte et qu'on nen tenait pas
compte donc ça ça a quand même fragilisé
à mon avis beaucoup euh le référendum je
reviens au au référendum effectivement à
l'époque de de De Gaulle quand même le
il y a deux éléments forts c'est la
guerre d'Algérie avec une question
importante qui on reste oou on s'en va
c'est-à-dire que là on était sur une
question qui engageait la nation comme
elle ne l'a plus été de depuis et la 2è
c'était l'élection suffrage universel du
président de la République bon ça a été
ça le 3isè il l'a perdu et le troisème
il l'a perdu euh alors que les Français
voulaient se débarrasser à ou a raison
de De Gaulle mais n'ont nullement
répondu le Sénat n'existerait plus si ça
avait été le cas donc peut-être qu'ils
ont bien fait de dire non je n'en sais
rien mais en tout cas ils n'ont pas
répondu à à la question même sous de
Gaulle on n'a pas répondu à la question
qui était posée donc je pense que
véritablement notre histoire du du
référendum est est une histoire qui est
n'a rien à
voir est toxique d'une certain manière
et qui a été instauré par De Gaulle sur
l'idée qu'il n'y a rien entre le peuple
et moi voilà et c'est pas du tout la
même philosophie dans les votations de
la Suisse c'est plébicitaire oui c'est
plébiscitaire on peut le d's pour ça
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'à mon avis
je pense que on ne peut pas avoir en
imaginant qu'on essaye encore on peut
pas avoir une culture référendaire en
France si on ne part pas et on ne pose
pas comme principe le fait que le
gouvernement ne partira pas oui ça ça me
semble indispensable jamais en Suisse un
électeur ne pense que si le gouvernement
perd le référendum il partira non et ça
je crois que c'est essentiel parce qu'il
faut justement que les gens votent sur
le sujet alors est-ce que c'est possible
ou pas possible là on verra mais ça je
crois que c'est très important et
Emmanuel Macron pourrait le dire il
pourrait l'expliquer et là aussi je suis
surpris du fait que sur ce terrain là il
ne fait aucune
pédagogie il me semble manquer aussi un
autre élément au génie Suisse par
rapport à notre culture référendire qui
est le fait d'accepter d'être mise en
minorité et
notamment on a par parler de la culture
du consensus mais en fait c'est vraiment
même une culture de l'opposition qui
manque à la France c'est-à-dire qu'à
partir du moment où toute une partie de
la population va s'être mobilisé où on
va avoir des campagnes référendaires le
caractère déceptif du référendum peut
encore créer ce mécanisme qui amène à ce
qu'on l'utilise plus parce qu'on n pas
tellement habitué à cette idée
rousseoiste du concept de volonté
générale si j'ai été en minorité c'est
peut-être que je n'avais pas raison sur
le moment et ça je crois que c'est
encore quelque chose sur lequel
l'opinion française a du mal à
travailler euh parmi les les chefs de
parti qui avaient accepté l'invitation
d'Emmanuel Macron au rencontre de
Saint-Denis il y avait Fabien Roussel je
vous propose de de l'écouter avec
écoutez bien la fin de son de sa prise
de parole je vais pas porter de jugement
sur ceux qui ont fait le choix de ne pas
venir parce que quelque part je peux
aussi les comprendre
euh il faut avoir un peu d'humilité euh
et et mesurer que c'est la deuxème
rencontre que l'on a ici
euh qui a le 493 qui tombe toutes les
semaines à l'Assemblée nationale et que
vraiment il y a une impasse démocratique
impasse démocratique voilà les mots sur
lesquels je voulais vous vous
entendreigbl est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette expression non on
n'est pas en dans une impase
démocratique aujourd'hui pourquoi on
fait du 493 en ce moment c'est le budget
et c'est on a parfaitement droit
d'utiliser le 493 or toute opposition ne
veut pas voter le budget parce que voter
le budget ça veut dire qu'on appartient
à la majorité or nous l'opposition ne
veut pas pouvoir être taxé appartenir à
la majorité donc systématiquement elle
vote compte ce que c'est parfaitement le
gouvernement donc la seule la France
doit avoir un budget et donc elle
utilise le 493 tout ça est un jeu de DUP
parce que l'opposition sait très bien
qu'on va utiliser le 493 et que donc la
France aura un budget et donc que ça
pourra fonctionner mais ça permet quand
même une tribune pour dire défi de
démocratie impasse démocratique quel
scandale et autre tout ça excusez-moi
c'est du théâtre totalement et le
gouvernement fait ce qu'il a à faire sur
ce puisque c'est effectivement un
instrument de la Constitution ce n'est
donc pas un déit de démocratie tout le
monde sait qu'on va l'utiliser et on
l'utilise impasse démocratique je vous
repose la la même question Anchin B et
puis je rajoute parce que dans dans la
prise de parole de Matthieu tout à
l'heure on a commencé à évoquer la
question de la la proportionnelle est-ce
que le fait de de d'introduire une dose
de proportionnel dans le Cetin
législatif serait une façon de sortir de
cet impass démocratique vous voyez elle
est double ma question la question
double un préférendum en quelque
euh moi je ne crois pas nécessairement
qu'on soit dans une crise
institutionnelle ni constitutionnelle ni
démocratique euh parce que on a utilisé
un petit peu tous ces tous ces
qualificatifs d'ailleurs pendant la la
réforme des retraites et je pense qu'il
y a un malaise en effet mais qui est pas
nécessairement un malaise de la
démocratie c'est un c'est un malaise du
sentiment de représentation c'est-à-dire
que les Français ont du mal avec leur
représentant et notamment avec le le
côté bouton pression bouton poussoir de
dire voilà j'ai lis quelqu'un pendant 5
ans et ensuite je ne me prononce plus
donc il y a il y a en effet quelque
chose de l'ordre de la respiration c'est
un terme que Emmanuel Macron aimait
beaucoup qu'il faut essayer de penser
est-ce que cette respiration on peut la
trouver dans la proportionnelle je n'en
suis pas sûr non plus parce que je crois
que nous avons une Assemblée nationale
qui aujourd'hui est digne d'une
Assemblée nationale de proportionnelle
parce que et c'est c'est ce que Mathieu
nous a dit parce que la fragmentation
c'est la caractéristique même de la
proportionnelle et on n'arrive pas à
travailler avec une majorité fragmentée
tout simplement parce que la 5e
République c'était Marcel prot qui
parlait du cor cor orthopédique et le
problème c'est qu'on s'est démusclé un
petit peu parce qu'on a tellement eu
l'habitude de ce corsé orthopédique que
notre système majoritaire fonctionne
même avec une majorité fracturée on a
l'habitude de suivre on a une discipline
partisane qui fait que les partis
n'aiment pas comme vous le disiez être
affilié ou être recensé et donc on ne
sait pas travailler ensemble donc je
crois pas que la proportionnelle
aiderait beaucoup mais je crois qu'il
faut enfin qu'on sorte de l'ornière en
apprenant peut-être à travailler
ensemble et encore une fois le budget
devrait être aussi le lieu d'un d'une
unanimité ça existe dans des grandes
démocratie qu'on ne s'oppose pas sur des
questions budgétaires parce qu'on sait
qu'elles sont vitales pour la nation on
parle de l'hypothèse une réforme
constitutionnelle plus ou moins grande
Richard verli est-ce que un un un
président dans cette situation politique
a la légitimité pour le pour la faire
cette réforme constitutionnelle il a en
tout cas la légitimité pour la proposer
et pour la pousser et moi ce qui me
frappe c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron donne
quand même l'impression de pousser des
choses mais de s'arrêter très vite en
chemin et c'est là où il y a le soupçon
de vouloir avant tout R de quand il y a
plus personne il va être tout seul face
à son miroir à un moment donc faut bien
qu'il s'arrête quoi oui je je trouve moi
je suis quand même euh euh j'avoue que
je suis dubitatif sur l'objectif je me
demande si Emmanuel Macron croit
vraiment aux propositions qu'il avance
je pense qu'il les il les met sur la
table parce qu'il a besoin on le sait il
a besoin de faire vivre le débat
politique il espère toujours Infiné
obtenir une majorité arriver à casser
l'un ou l'autre parti mais donc on peut
pas lui reprocher de proposer on peut
peut-être lui reprocher de ne pas assez
persister ou en tout cas de persister
dans une seule voix c'est-à-dire de se
retrouver vant debout les partis
politiques mais ça ne suffit pas il y a
peut-être d'autres moyens je ne sais pas
il y a quelque chose quand même depuis
sa victoire à la à la présidentielle de
2022 et depuis surtout sa défaite entre
guillemets au législatif puisqueon
rappelle qu'ils ont la majorité relative
mais ils nonont pas une majorité absolue
c'est une espèce de volonté de démontrer
par l'absurde que la faute incombe à
l'opposition donc il est il l'avait fait
dès le début vous vous souvenez en
disant qu'il fallait recevoir tous les
chefs de parti on par d'union nationale
en juin 2022 et il avait dit il avait
après il avait fait une intervention
télévisée pour dire regardez ça ne
marche pas c'est pas de notre fête c'est
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas et il y a un
peu toujours cette idéelà de j'aurais
tout tenté jusqu'au jour où
j'appuieraiis sur le bouton disolution
diss solution en disant on a tout tenté
c'est ce ils n'en veulent pas j'ai lancé
le CNR ils n'en veulent pas j'ai fait
les rencontres de Saint ils n'en veulent
pas ils font vraiment voilà incapable de
d'intérêt général on a quelque chose
voilà comme s'il instruisait un dossier
avec toujours un sous-titre
rappelez-vous dans ses allocutions il a
a dit il n'y a pas de majorité
alternative donc c'est c'est vrai que
c'est très troublant et je suis de la
vie de Mathieu batrice Giblin oui mais
c'est il faut dire aussi que
l'opposition lui donne raison ah bah je
dire si si elle s'y prenait autrement
euh voilà ça se passe pourrait se passer
tout à fait tout à fait oui mais là sur
les rencontres de Saint-Denis on en
avait d'ailleurs parlé ensemble je crois
que c'était la semaine dernière le enfin
la ficelle était quand même tellement
grosse que enfin la main tendue à la
droite est tellement grosse que c'est ce
que Mat disais tout à l'heure il y avait
un piège pour la gauche un piège pour
droite bref oui mais néanmoins peut-être
être un peu crédule de d'imaginer qu'ils
allent tomber dedans oh ça serait est-ce
que le piège n'a pas été de pas venir
parce que d'une certaine façon sioti
brandisait son brandit son référendum de
l'immigration il y a que Bardella pour
le défendre et tout le monde est contre
excusez-moi mais la chaise vide là pour
le coup ça on peut pas dire que ça lui a
vraiment rendu service et je peux pas
dire que ça
puisse vraiment augmenter la crédibilité
du leader des LR en ce moment enfin pour
moi c'est très très curieux à force
d'avoir peur de pas tomber dans le piège
on sera pas on se rend pas compte qu'on
tombe dans celui d'à côté mais pas dans
celui qui vous avez été la politique
c'est du judo hein et c'est êt capable
précisément de retourner
voilà ne pas être capable de le faire
c'est c'est pas
derère chose c'est que l'opposition ne
prend pas la mesure de la véritable
inquiétude d'une grande partie de des de
nos concitoyens et qui
sont inquiets préoccupés d'une classe
politique qui dans ce jeul
ne n'a pas l'air de prendre la mesure de
ce qu'il faudrait faire et ça moi je
suis très très inquiète pas savoir si
c'est bien Macron ou pas Macron ils font
ce qu'ils peuvent avec ce ce qu'ils ont
mais qu'on est sur un terrain
extrêmement difficile et au vu des
résultats des élections en Argentine et
ben ça n'arrive pas qu'aux autres euh
vous parliez de la politique de la
chaise vide d'éic Coti le président du
parti LR ça a permis à Jordan Bardella
le président du Rassemblement national
d'être dans cette posture à l'issue des
rencontres de Saint-Denis il est clair
qu'autour de la table ensemble des
formations politiques qu'ell soit de la
majorité ou de gauche ne souhaite pas ce
référendum sur l'immigration elle ne
souhaite pas ce référendum sur
l'immigration parce que ce référendum
sur l'immigration donnerait raison au
rassemblement national donc je comprends
que ce sujet gêne aujourd'hui le pouvoir
qu'il gêne une partie de l'opposition et
notamment à gauche moi je continue de
porter cette demande parce que je crois
qu'elle est très largement réclamée par
le peuple français Richard verli est-ce
que vous parlez là d'un cadeau
finalement fait au rassemblement
national écoutez rassemblement national
sur ce sujet il faut quand même
reconnaître qu'il est cohérent moi il se
trouve que on parlait du voyage
d'Emmanuel Macron en Suisse j'ai
intervieoué Marine Le Pen sur le sujet
de la démocratie directe elle elle elle
a pris le sujet à brascor elle a
d'ailleurs expliqué un certain nombre de
différences elle estime que le modèle
suisse ne serait pas importable en
France à partir du moment où ils font le
job et ils sont cohérents il faut quand
même pas s'étonner qu'à un moment donné
les électeurs se le le voient et le
constate alors on peut en penser ce
qu'on veut mais le fait est sur ce
terrain il y a une persistance il y a
une cohérence et il y a aussi il faut
connaître une somme de travaux moi j'ai
pu voir que le rassemblement national
consulte travaille sur la manière de
faire un éventuel référendum je dirais
voilà c'est c'est ça que il faut si on
veut les contester il faut les contester
sur ce terrain pas simplement à coup
d'unathème alors on l'a appris à
l'occasion de ces rencontre de
Saint-Denis le le principe d'un
référendum sur l'immigration n'est plus
à l'ordre du jour faute de consensus
politique on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
en revanche la réforme de la
Constitution pour permettre ce
référendum elle est encore d'actualité
notamment chez les républicains je
propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
bonsoir Steve bienvenue à vous on va
remonter quelques mois en arrière en mai
en mai dernier appelez-vous les trois
leaders de la droite Eric cotti Olivier
marlex Bruno rotailleux annoncé en
grande pompe deux textes de loi sur
l'immigration annonce fait dans les
pages du JDD il faut reprendre le
contrôle disait-il alors à l'unition
plus de 6 mois mois plus tard il demande
toujours un élargissement de l'article
11 de la Constitution objectif pouvoir
organiser précisément un référendum sur
l'immigration écoutez malheureusement
aujourd'hui quand un parlementaire quand
le Parlement vote la loi les cours
suprêmes la détricote nous voulons nous
et nous avons proposé une modification
constitutionnelle nous voulons un
référendum nous voulons élargir
l'article 11 qui permettrait d'avoir un
référendum sur cette question tout
simplement parce que quand le peuple
tranche le conseil
et si on veut changer les choses en
sincérité il faut voter une réforme
constitutionnelle voilà au Sénat le
texte sera examiné le 12 décembre a-t-il
une chance d'être adopté non non
probablement pas Thomas on se va sortir
notre
calculation on aime beaucoup le lundi la
majorité sénatoriale il faut le rappeler
à chaque fois c'est 133 sénateurs LR et
56 élu du groupe Union centriste sur un
total de 348 sénateurs la droite aura
donc besoin des centristes pour faire
adopter un tel texte c'est vraiment
vraiment pas gagné on va voir ce que
nous dit Philippe boncarer le rapporteur
du précédent texte immigration ici au
Sénat il y a des éléments dans ce texte
sur lesquels nous n'aurons pas la
possibilité de suivre le groupe LR je ne
suis pas sûr qu'un accord entre nous
deux groupes soit possible mais je
suggère une concertation afin de ne pas
revivre la dramaturgie de l'article 3 du
texte immigration on s'en souvient le
texte immigration adopté la semaine
dernière en admettant même que le Sénat
adopte vote cette réforme
constitutionnelle il faudra ensuite
qu'elle arrive à l'Assemblée nationale
avec une majorité macroniste même
minoritaire et bien il faudra euh
qu'elle trouvait ses tous ces députés là
c'est sans doute pas possible j'ai perdu
mes mot mais j'essaie de de récupérer
ensuite révision constitutionnelle
oblige Thomas il faudra que 3 cè des
élus au Parlement votent et bien ce
texte réuni en Congrès parti comme c'est
parti ça va pas aller bien loin j'ai
retrouvé mes mots merci beaucoup St
Jourdain pour toutes ces explications
Anne Charline Bina on l'a déjà déjà dit
ici mais je je voudrais bien qu'on qu'on
le réexplique c'est certainement le pire
moment pour lancer une réforme une
réforme de du référendum c'est ce qu'on
est en train de comprendre sûrement le
pire moment et sûrement le pire sujet
également parce que le référendum n'est
pas contrairement à ce qu'a pu croire
Emmanuel Macron un sujet
particulièrement consensuel notamment
parce que comme on l'a dit on a une
culture un peu particulière avec ça et
parce que ouvrir le référendum à
différentes questions ça pose question
parce que il faut savoir pourquoi les
questions sociétales on été exclu en 58
parce que c'est difficile de de diviser
la population entre par exemple sur
l'avortement les pro choice les prif et
c'est quelque chose qu' qu'on a pas
souhaité mettre en place en France et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'on soit forcément mû
sur la plupart des questions pour en
arriver là mais
surtout la révision constitutionnelle
elle est pas obligée du tout de passer
par un congrès des 35è des membres du
Parlement elle peut passer elle-même par
référendum
néanmoins le fait
qu'onim ça prouve bien que même sur la
question du référendum a pe réérendum
donc je crois qu'il faut faire attention
à penser aussi j'ai l'impression qu'en
fait le le président Macron c'est un peu
mépris sur ce qu'il pouvait faire sur sa
seule personne et ça c'est un peu le le
myth de la 5e République c'est que il y
a cette figure tellement forte du
président de la République que il croit
pouvoir parfois réunir sur sa personne
c'est un peu ce qu'il avait fait pendant
le grand débat avec les maires de France
et là sur les rencontres de Saint-Denis
précisément sur ces sujets-l ça ne
fonctionne pas mais Béatrice giin dans
la proposition du du du parti il y a
aussi une fausse promesse il sait très
bien même quand il met cette question de
d'une révision constitutionnelle pour
intégrer les questions d'immigration sur
au champ du référendum c'est très bien
que la majorité sera pas là enfin que
que c'est que c'est un chemin tellement
semé dans bûche qu'il est impossible
c'est pour ça que je dis qu'on est au
théâtre c'est pour ça que je dis qu'on
fait semblant voilà on fait semblant de
de s'opposer
fermement l'optique est une optique
véritablement électoral je suis pas sûr
que ce soit d'ailleurs la bonne
stratégie pour récupérer un électorat
mais ils le savent que ça ne va pas a
passé faut pas raconter d'histoire à la
limite s'il avait eu peur que ça passe
c'est pour ça qu'il y est pas allé au au
rencontrre de Saint-Denis par ça il
était pas là donc il pouvait pas le
défendre enfin il y a là quelque chose
pour pour moi c'est véritablement un jeu
de dupe à un moment où je pense que la
conscience politique des Français ne le
supporte plus et alors ceux qui semblent
comme le disait Richard est limite
cohérent et qui vote quand c'est
nécessaire de voter
qui travaille comme le fait en ce moment
le RN lui donne une
crédibilité que ça nous plaise ou que ça
nous plaise pas et moi je rejoins
Richard c'est pas dans la logique de
l'anathème qu'on va essayer d'arranger
quelque chose et et et la situation est
vraiment très différente vous av vous
avzquel rard mais rard on avait quoi on
navait pas un rè aussi puissant hein pas
du tout bon et on navait pas non plus
une gauche
qui SAV travaill
et ça arrive que les partis réussissent
à travailler ensemble ici au Sénat ou
même en commission mixte paritaire par
de gouvernement par de
gouvern je veux dire il faut aussi
regarder des deux côtés du du sûr mais
là où c'est quand même un peu
problématique si vous voulez c'est que
ce parti de gouvernement quita LR il se
retrouve avec une soixantaine de députés
c'est pas beaucoup une soantaine de
déput et du coup le fait d'avoir perdu
cette assise qu'il avait fait qu'il est
à mon sens fait l'erreur d'aller sur un
discours beaucoup plus radical qu'il
n'est dans sa j'allais dire dans sa
traduction c'est pas ce qu'on voit ici
c'est pas ce qu'on voit au Sénat mais
véritablement c'est ce qu'on voit à
l'Assemblée avec des positions alors
Infiné ils vont voter comme le dit
toujours ellisabeth por mais j'en ai
fait passer 49 sur 52 c'est pas si mal
de mes lois ce qui est vrai V mais la
perception qu'ont les citoyens français
c'est pas celle-là c'est c'est j'ai
parlé le terme de blocage il y a pas
blocage dans les faites je suis d'accord
avec vous mais
néanmoins ce qui est perçu je pense par
l'opinion publique c'est que c'est
vraiment un grand un grand n'importe
quoiie de la même façon qu'Emmanuel
Macron fait tout pour montrer que c'est
la faute de l'opposition les oppositions
font tout pour montrer que c'est la
faute d'emuel Macron et donc du coup on
est dans une situation de blocage avec
Rocard c'est que la classe politique
elle était divisée une droite il av une
gauche mais tous ces gens-là se
connaissaient ils gérai parfois des
collectivités locales ensemble il se
côtoyaaiit sur les bandes du Parlement
depuis des années là on a vu l'irruption
de nouveau venu entre guillemets lors
des législative que ce soit LFI que ce
soit leur assemblé nationale en nombre
en 2017 on aait déjà eu un petit peu
mais là vraiment en nombre qui n'ont pas
du tout l'habitude de ces j'allais dire
de ces de cette fabrication de la
politique de cette fabrication
parlementaire et qui sont mis avec deux
attitudes très différentes elle et fille
faisant tout pour montrer que c'est la
faute d'emuel Macron et le rassemblement
national à la surprise générale jouant
le jeu de la recherche du compromis
quand ça l'arrange avec les hypocrises
quiarrange mais jouant le jeu du
compromis l'autre différence avec
l'époque de michelart il y a 30 ans 40
ans 30 ans c'est la différence d'époque
aujourd'hui le référendum dans l'opinion
c'est quelque chose de très populaire
parce que ça correspond à l'époque le
référendum on vote sur surtout on vote
avec son portable on choisit on like en
permanence donc chez les jeunes
générations le référendum c'est quelque
chose de très sexy entre guillemets et
c'est aussi ça je pense qu'Emmanuel
Macron a compris parce qu'il est très
attentif à ces générations et à Cees
mouvement d'opinion donc faisons
attention quand même parce que si la
classe politique française est perçue
comme antiréférendum comme empêchant le
référendum la colère d'une partie de
l'opinion va monter mais alors dans ce
cas-là pourquoi ne pas réformer le
référendum d'initiative partagé parce
que c'était une une autre piste alors là
on on est on est aussi dans le champ
référendum aujourd'hui il faut 10 % du
corps électoral c'est ça 4 millions voir
plus presque presque 5 de d'électeurs
enfin c'est beaucoup trop et de toute
façon on le voit bien principe de
réalité ça n'a jamais été mise en œuvre
pour pourquoi cette réforme du Rip ne
voit pas le jour d'après vous c'est une
vraie question je vais me permettre
quand même de faire un tout petit retour
sur ce qu'on disait je crois que c'est
pas à noing que sur l'immigration et sur
la question du référendum sur
l'immigration les LR il aille avec des
gros sabot et ça nourrit en fait une
stratégie de l'empêchement qui est très
typique du sujet de l'immigration où
vous pouvez mettre la responsabilité sur
les institutions de l'Union européenne
sur Schengen sur la Convention de Genève
et et malheureusement vous parliez de du
caractère très déceptif de de de
l'absence de référendum je crois aussi
que sur cette question de l'immigration
ça nourrit des populismes c'est-à-dire
que à partir du moment où on laisse
entendre que on ne peut pas gouverner et
que la politique est empêchée c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment interro
dangereux avec discours aussi sur la
primuté du droit européen on voit qu'il
y a des
pays comme la polne qui sont dans cette
démche qui fait partie de la proposition
constitutionnelle des LR l'idée est de
sortir en tout cas de de permettre
d'atténuer la la force des traités donc
attention à ne pas utiliser la parole du
peuple comme un instrument et pour le
RIB je vous rejoins en effet c'est
quelque chose qui a été tellement mal
ficelé en 2008 que aujourd'hui on ne
peut quasiment pas l'utiliser pourquoi
ne pas le changer peut-être qu'on a pas
pris le problème du bon côté
c'est-à-dire que certes le problème
c'est certainement les seuils mais c'est
surtout la procédure en tant que telle
aujourd'hui pour utiliser un RIP il faut
que le Parlement ne se soit pas saisi
pendant 6 mois du sujet pour que le
président soit et encore pas totalement
lié pour faire un référendum donc voyez
toutes les étapes de la procédure
auraient mérité d'être revu pour tout
simplement créer un droit de pétition
citoyen pourquoi avoir peur du
référendum abrogatif également on peut
revenir sur des lois qui viennent d'être
voté l'Italie la Suisse le démontre donc
la question de la concurrence des
légitimité qu'Emmanuel Macron a a agité
comme une limite comme un chiffon rouge
a peut-être aussi braqué le débat
Béatrice GI votre avis là-dessus est-ce
que ce référendum initiative partagé
rénové ce serait pas le moyen le plus
simple de redonner la parole au peuple
entre deux grandes élections nationales
Anne Charlotte vient d'évoquer le droit
de pétition ça a existé on pourrait
parfaitement repartir de ça avec un
certain nombre à tout niveau au niveau
local au niveau régional au niveau
national ça serait parfaitement possible
avec un certain nombre évidemment
d'électeurs inscrit sur les listes
électorales on partirait pas n'importe
comment dans les compétences de de
chaque strate bien sûr mais à partir du
moment où on aurait ce ce niveau-là on
peut le mettre au niveau national non
plus à 10 % mais peut-être à 5 % ça
c'est quand même plus facile à atteindre
et à ce moment-là on peut parfaitement
relancer la possibilité de discuter soit
c'est le Parlement qui est obligé de
prendre en charge cette demande
pétitionnaire de la part des citoyens
soit ce la pétition qui amène à abroger
ce qui a pu être fait je pense que ça
pourrait parfaitement être envisageable
mais là je rejoins no nos deux
intervenants je crois qu'il y a une peur
il y a une peur de se confronter à ça on
ne fait pas confiance en ce qu'ils sont
capables c'est foutu français de on a
peur du peuple disons les
chosesons a peur du peuple dire
forcément que le Parlement est affaibli
par un système comme celui-là
l'hypothèse d'un référendum révocatoire
alors moi je là encore on peut prendre
l'exemple de de la Suisse oui mais alors
je ne le pense pas mais attention dans
le cas de la Suisse et c'est ce que je
dis toujours vous ne pouvez pas délier
la démocratie directe de la forme de
gouvernement du pays qui est extrêmement
décentralisé où vous avez l'essentiel
des décisions qui se prennent au niveau
cantonal et donc en fait vous avez un un
un pouvoir en quelque sorte tricéfale un
un exécutif un législatif et la volonté
populaire à travers le référendum il est
vrai quand même disons-le que si la
culture référend mais on est on en est
très loin devait prospérer en France à
un moment donné le législateur serait un
peu plus coincé serait un peu plus
corseté pour reprendre l'expression
d'Anne Charlen parce que ça veut dire
qu'à tout moment le peuple si un droit
d'initiative réelle existe le peuple
peut s'interposer et dire la loi que
l'Assemblée a voté et bien on n veut pas
ça en général les élus n'aiment pas même
dernier mot mais on a aussi quand même
le droit constitutionnel on a aussi le
cette ce comité qui veille sur la
constitutionnalité des lois donc je
pense qu'on a des gardes de fous face à
cela et que on devrait pas forcément
avoir tellement peur de de cela je je
pense pas en revanche ce que tu dis
Richard est très juste c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes sur un système depuis
longtemps un système fédéral avec du
poids sur les cantons et que nousû nous
l'histoire de la France c'est une
histoire de
centralisation c'est le livre de Pascal
Orri ce cher et vieux pays quand tout le
monde fonctionne dans des démocraties
qu'il appelle des roseaux nous sommes un
chaîne qui qui résiste la verticalité
voilà on va terminer là-dessus
magnifique citation merci à tous d'avoir
participé à à ce débat Richard verli je
rappelle que vous avez donc lancé ce
podcast qui s'appelle elvtic café très
bon titre de tous conv et ben voilà
on va on va suivre ça demain c'est
Brigitte Macron au programme c'est bien
ça merci encore à tous d'être venu sur
sur le plateau de sens public